it's time for screen junkies boobie buds
that's a great story Rachel but I'll
pick that up later you guys welcome to
movie fights it is all happening we have
competitors colliding on a movie
battlefield a lot of excitements going
to go down I'm Hal Rudnick I am your
host and let's meet today's fighters now
if you tuned in expecting mark and Draco
you're Sol mark I ran into a little car
trouble and we can't wait to have him
back soon but we got a pretty good
replacement in the form of mr. dan merle
dan what is a I was literally the
closest person nearby shifted over from
the seat to here yes we fun it's a no
fight how hell yeah good time I mean if
anyone could do it it's you I mean but
against this competition yes no very
tough competition um we are so excited
to have this woman on the show you've
seen her just destroy in the Schmo down
and she is just a very knowledgeable
movie a cineast a film lover welcome
Rachel Cushing thank you for having me
but I gotta say there wasn't anybody
closer than Dan Merle nobody in this
entire office it had to be Dan yeah
thanks guys thanks for throwing me in
the deep end yeah I mean for your first
one we just want to go up against the
longest-reigning movie fights champion
we've ever had my hands are shaking all
right maybe you're just playing possum
maybe you're like like Brer Rabbit like
throw me in the briar patch oh yeah okay
anything you want to plug Rachel
anything you want to tell us about uh
just uh you know Schmo down Dan
considered the greatest of all time and
I'm gunning for that record myself so I
have a title match coming up so
hopefully guys tune in to the movie
trivia Schmo down for that at the end of
the month but other than that I'm happy
to be here at screen junkies awesome
thanks for being here Rachel oh boy so
for those of you who are new or
rejoining us just a little bit of a
synopsis of how we break down each
battle and how we
we have three judges myself usually uh
Dan Murr will be the fact-checker but
today sitting in the fact-check seat we
got mr. Juan Harris one delighted to be
here and filling in for Dan he was the
closest to get to the podium and then I
was the closest to fill this seat that's
how we do yes Dan delighted to be in
Madana thank you for holding it down on
the fact checking lon what is your like
what is your mantra when it comes to
fact-checking
hope that I don't have to do very much
of it because I really like to listen
intently get into the arguments and then
we get to the end of the arguments and
I'm like oh I was supposed to be the one
making sure everything was factual it's
a little stressful it is stressful
but you can I'm sure you can handle it
so Juan and I will be casting our votes
and then the third vote goes to you and
that will be delivered to us by the
wonderful Danielle Radford Danielle what
is up what is up so those of you if you
haven't been watching the way that we've
been working with the votes now is if
you want to cast your vote there is a
poll it is you tube only not on Twitter
YouTube only and that poll shows up once
both fighters have given their answers
that way there's like no spoils ease if
you don't see it and you've been
watching you can obviously either
refresh or you can hit that I card when
it comes up and it's on the upper
right-hand side of your screen and that
is where it's going to be if you don't
see it drop down below hit the
annotations just flick it off and on the
icon should pop up and you should be
able to vote then I will also be
checking for all of your sick dankmemes
oh hell yes
as Albert likes and anything funny y'all
have to say any great observations I
will make fun of you because I love you
and that's how we train you nice Thank
You Danielle sent Danielle nothing but
love and also send her photoshop's
photo-ops
dank memes exactly Thank You lon and
Danielle so without further ado take to
evil
ladies and gents its main event time
[Music]
thanks JT you've got one hell of a
package so just to review how this works
we have three regular round questions
and then after the three regular round
questions we go to a four question speed
round and it is any persons game at that
point if someone is up three two zero
there's four questions where you can
make it up wow what an event is in store
for us today all right Dan you ready for
question number one let's do it Rachel
you feelin it alright alright here we go
question one what movie should inspire
an anthology series Wow
man that is a tough question but these
two competitors have boiled it down Dan
let's hear from you first
well I think what you have to look at
the spirit of what they've been try to
do it's like Cloverfield is different
stories taking place in a similar
universe that has some kind of a tying
you know a piece tying them all together
but can be distinct from each other and
I thought I would take one of the
biggest hit movies from last year which
was it which if you know the book is an
extremely dense book that was condensed
into a four hour TV miniseries it was
condensed into the movie that we saw
last year one of the things that they
had to leave out of the new movie just
because of time constraints was this the
the idea that derry this town where they
live in is you know on a cyclical nature
every time the monster really is
something terrible happens and this
could they go - they don't very deeply
into this in the book there's a mob rub
out there's a factory explosion and the
idea that this town is kind of the
sinister evil it's inherently evil and
it and it resurfaces every almost three
decades I think you could have fun with
that I think there's a way to make a
series of films and a series of stories
that can be very distinct stylistically
that can be very distinct and the kinds
of characters it has the kind of stories
it tells but that has these things the
town of Derry you can track certain
families you can track certain people
off across two or three different movies
then I think you could tie them all very
neatly together into this kind of
tapestry of the town but you know given
the different eras I think they could be
diff
stylistically and I think that's what
you're going for with an anthology
series it's a common thread that you can
have fun and have room to operate in and
I think that there's enough there and
that mythology you can go back 200 300
years you can go you know 20 years or 40
years I think you'd have some fun with
that and I think it'd be a fun series of
movies
there we go Stephen King's it Rachel
okay well I am also going to look to
last year for my inspiration and that is
go big or go home
and that's the mantra I'm sticking to
and there was a movie that went real big
it swung for the fences arguably it
missed but in the core level there is a
foundation here to build an anthology
off of and that is luc besson valerian
in the city of a thousand planets my
common thread with this is setting we're
gonna throw out all the terrible aspects
of this movie and believe me there are
terrible aspects about this movie Dane
DeHaan gone are de Lavigne gone I don't
get the hype around her I really don't
one-dimensional villains Clive Owen and
little CGI creatures that poop pearls
gone out the airlock we don't need any
of that but we do have alpha which is
literally called the city of a thousand
planets might as well say that's a city
of a thousand stories there is so many
possibilities here and it's not just
possibilities in creatures and
characters
it's possibilities in genre you can have
a horror movie set on one level with
certain creatures you can have a comedy
you could have a drama you could have a
political thriller you could have an
underworld pirate movie there are so
many possibilities in so many areas in
which you can take risks but it is all
connected via this station alpha and if
they go well you can even go beyond that
with other planets and what better place
to set a universe than the universe so I
think that in terms of anthologies you
want the movies to be tied together in
certain ways but you want to be able to
branch out and take risks in other ways
and my favorite parts of this movie were
was the world was the creatures was the
imagination there are so many
possibilities here that it's the perfect
foundation for an anthology Wow okay
two very different recent films fight it
out you guys
well my issue with valerian would be
that I almost see like this room for too
much variance I think that's kind of
where Cloverfield has failed a little
bit in the way that they're going is
they say like oh it's an anthology
series but the connective tissue behind
them doesn't really make sense and I you
know I think when you aren't when you
don't really coherently tie the movies
together and anyway I think it's kinda
like well why don't why not just shed
this burden of having to be part of a
shared universe and just make a movie
secondly I think that we are so
inundated right now with space fantasy
guardians it's the way that the MCU is
going largely Thor was out in space
doing space fantasy obviously Star Wars
I feel like it would be hard for a
Valyrian series to distinguish itself
from what so many other movies are doing
so well so I think you're just kind of
flooding the marketplace with a lot of
movies that seem like the same and then
just from a practical standpoint I just
don't know if valerian has the cachet to
successfully launch something because
that first movie did leave a bad taste
in a lot of people's mouths and you're
essentially jettisoning everything
except for you know the name I guess I
just I I wonder if audiences will even
embrace something when they've already
shunned what it came from if you want to
talk about oversaturation horror films
there's more than enough horror films
out there in terms of genre and that's
the problem with setting it in it is
that that narrows the genre too much
you're basically talking Stephen King
which you're basically talking horror he
has a little variation and you're even
talking about just a town I don't think
there's enough distinction there you're
talking about distinction with some
characters and maybe eras but that's it
I think that anthologies like something
like the MCU are too tied together what
we want to see is something that gives
more variety more risk more ideas to be
creative that's what filmmaking is about
I don't think we should think about
ontology in narrow terms I think we
should think about them and much broader
sense and I think that they keep making
space operas and I'm not even saying all
these films have to be space operas
because there is an audience for it I'm
the audience for it I wanted to love
valeri and a lot of people did so I'm
saying take the bits that we did
and do something with those and make
more people love it
I just think that valerian was all
surface and when the movie even tried to
scratch into the the bottom of it at all
that's when it fell apart it was all
style but that's all these can do right
that's what I'm saying take I'm not
saying this is a good movie it's a good
movie this is not but there are great
elements to it and I think setting is
the best way to set up yourself for an
anthology and for a variety of ideas let
me ask you a specific question about
valerian so if we jettison cara
delevingne and dane dehaan and the rest
of the cast as you said what is where do
we get the foothold as the viewer what
is get me more excited and fill me in a
little bit more on the tie that binds
its alpha it's this imaginary place the
best four minutes of this movie is the
opening four minutes it's an opening
credits and it is this series of
meetings between different races and the
city of Alpha the space station grows
and it gets bigger and more intricate
and you get more and more greetings and
you just get this great sense of story
in an opening credit sequence about all
of these imaginative races and people
and think about the stories you could
tell about who they are what they're
doing how they relate to each other tell
family stories about that tell adventure
stories about that tell horror stories
about that there's so many imaginative
great out-of-the-box ideas in that movie
that are bright and colorful and
interesting and the movie didn't scratch
below the surface but other directors
could that's my pitch danly throne
question at you
so what would make this anthology series
of it different from say a series of
horror movies like the Freddy Krueger
movies or something like that would this
recurring big bad character well I mean
did the problem with the Freddy Krueger
movies is that they were so tied to one
character and I think that what gets
lost when you look at the big picture of
it is it becomes all about Pennywise and
when you look deeper down into the
mythology that Stephen King builds it's
like Pennywise is the manifestation of
this evil but the town itself its
citizens they don't see certain things
they're blind to certain things there's
things that they don't notice and it's
because over a period of centuries this
this town has become just like a like a
like a like a sinkhole for evil and
so I love these kind of overarching
Gothic tales that build a tapestry that
build a world out of you know you see
the background and and what comes out of
this thing you know you see it tells you
very specific stories of these kids and
these times than these kids when they
grow up there were generations of kids
there were generations of citizens there
were generations and decades and eras of
evil that manifested themselves and
there's horror movies there aren't a lot
of horror movies and there are a lot of
horror movies for a reason it's because
the horror genre lends itself to being
adapted so well stylistically tonally
therefore they're funny horror movies
there are scary horror movies they're
sci-fi there's body horror there's so
many different ways to go in the genre
kind of like the point you were making
inside the sci-fi in space there's so
many different ways you can go inside of
that genre and again like I think that
space movies are fun but you know if you
have infinite possibilities why tie
yourself to this one place whereas I
think that the place the setting in the
the dairy anthology series that's what
ties it all together that's what the
unifying thread is is you're telling the
story of this place I think that's what
makes it an anthology series because
when you back out and you look at all
the movies in totality each one tells a
separate story and it's painting a much
larger picture that you're seeing of
this town and I think that's what makes
a great anthology series sure
lastly I'd love for each of you just to
throw me just that much more vivid and
specific examples of what you would
envision maybe a couple of your movies
in this anthology series being either if
you can jump in and start I love the
idea of this is like a maze that's one
of the things that was in valyrian was
that going through all the layers and
the levels and whatnot so a family where
one member is lost and having to find
them I like the idea of politics I like
these different races why are they
coming together why did they join up in
alpha there have to be difference there
there's differences in class so there's
all kinds of dramatic stories you can
tell with that and then just fun space
adventures I mean John Goodman voices a
pirate I mean who doesn't want a pirate
so story set in space we love that that
is definitely a different version a
different story within this city which
is the unifying aspect of this it's
still unified but it's still broad at
the same time gotcha
damn any
specifically well there's one stories
they tell that takes place back in the
1920s it tell us about this kind of
outlaw gang that rides into town and
they're basically ambushed by the entire
town and massacred and essentially it's
the fact that you know this evil spirit
manifested through Pennywise who takes
many different forms it's kind of leads
the town toward this mob mentality that
just results in this Massacre so I see
like kind of a 1920s gangland movie you
follow this gang of Outlaws they've they
roll into this town something Crazy's
goin on you see something going on with
the populace it's kind of a pod people
type thing we're like you know they're
the outlaws but they keep getting these
weird signs these weird angles and again
it's creepy and it just builds bigger
and bigger and bigger from this kind of
what seems like a 20s crime story to the
supernatural kind of what's bubbling
underneath the surface and so you have
this big kind of explosion at the end of
this kind of unspeakable act of violence
and you and you get a picture of what's
actually going on in this town so you're
sticking with King but I'm hoping to
give more people more writers more
filmmakers free rein I think there's
more interesting more innovative more
creative out-of-the-box things to do
rather than just go back to Stephen King
King is a temp that's a template of a
story that's in that novel but what I'm
saying is the great thing about the fact
that this creature has been there for
centuries is you can't expand beyond
that mythos obviously that's one that's
in the established canon but you can go
pretty much to any time from prehistoric
to now and still have that one kind of
unifying threat which i think is very
important is to have some kind of
unifying thread time okay Wow poof what
a barnburner that was right out of the
gate I hope it inspired a couple of
dankmemes we'll get to that in a minute
so you know what I think you had a bit
of an uphill battle Rachel yeah it's Dan
yeah it's a and Stan Merle a legend in
movie fighting but I also you picked a
movie that was is not beloved and met
with the what's the opposite of being
beloved
but misunderstood so and Dan's opening
salvo and it's just it really painted a
picture of something we'd like to
explore but then you got me thinking
about all of these possibilities of this
world there it's pretty limitless and
that's exciting and oh and by the way to
answer one of your questions the appeal
of Cara Delevingne is the eyebrows is it
I think so but so I give you major kudos
Rachel for like like painting this
picture of something like I never would
have considered that and now I'm like
yeah but at the end of the day I feel
like we had to jettison too much that
from the first film and we don't get an
idea you said it yourself that it was
the first four minutes and I mean
compared with this town that has an evil
that spans potentially limitless amounts
of time with stories from so many
different time periods and this
Pennywise that the manifestation of evil
that worked so well in this last film I
feel like Dan really sold that and who I
mean I don't mind Stephen King you say
it only goes from like Stephen King I
feel like yes if you're gonna pick one
writer to do an anthology series
inspired by so at the end of the day
Rachel I felt like it take took some
great swings but I got to give it to Dan
he made something just that seems that
much closer to being a real thing lon
one Oh Dan what are your thoughts I got
I have no incorrect facts to check one
interesting thing is that both fighters
actually picked properties that have a
ton of other material that you could
consult so they're both interesting
choices for anthologies there's 12
Stephen King books that refer back to
dairy plus a variety of short stories
and valerian has is based on a popular
long-running French sci-fi comic series
that when
1967 to 2010 so these are media
franchises and intellectual property who
could pick four anthologies for a long
time nobody brought that up in the round
but I thought it was an interesting
point to bring up I this was really
tough they both made a lot of great
points dan really had me for most of the
fight and then he was talking about you
know that you can do all these various
tones and horror films you know and that
it's sort of Rachel's has sort of locked
into a single location and honestly
after hearing them out I was like I feel
like all of those things actually
applied to both of these ideas and I
really liked Rachel's point about that
it would be you know it's not gonna be
just these sort of Stephen King esque
stories it's going to be a lot of
different kinds of stories that all have
like a little sci-fi element because
alpha is such a varied crazy environment
and I feel like I liked valerian a
little bit more than most people so I'm
gonna give this one to Rachel
boom we are locked up at 1-1 we're going
to the fans Danielle all right let me
just I want to make sure I have the most
up to the minute to do because it's been
going it's been back in fourth disease
um but I have to say the good people of
the screen junkie and the universe they
have sided with valerian at 53% to 46%
Wow that's it come from behind
Valerius yeah but they loved they loved
crushers arguments so nice for a couple
of things that I saw that I was really
digging the ohio review on twitter said
an Iron Giant anthology series about the
creators of the Iron Giant throughout
the galaxy that sounds pretty dope and
then two people did some deep dives on
some things they thought one is at David
pockets ninety I won an anthology series
inspired by six streams samurai just
crazy over the top road warrior styled
action films focus on old school
musicians and then went through and
named a bunch of them I'm not going to
do them all here go check out that bro
whoa I'm a bridge yeah Jack Shipley or
at GRS pip-boy 2008 but I want to do it
in Thal G of all the Disney parents who
have died either before the movie starts
or die soon ass
okay the child ruining anthology there's
also a very detailed read that follows
that so if you want to go check that out
some people were just doing some long
reads
man interesting stuff dark dark any
memes okay no circus Wow um Cushing
crushing right out of the gate okay it
is one oh and let's go to question
numero dos what's the best movie ever
that's based on a children's book best
movie ever based on a children's book
Wow
Oh a library full of answers Rachel
there really is and as an avid book
reader this was very tough but at the
same time my brain went to this movie
first and it struck me as the absolutely
the right one and it's not gonna
surprise anybody who knows me that I am
calling out a Harry Potter movie and
that it's Harry Potter and the Prisoner
of Azkaban and the reason is not just
based on the revolution that JK Rowling
started with the Harry Potter books
because pretty much prior to that
reading was not cool I would know
reading fantasy was especially not cool
I would especially know this about that
age and then along comes this series
that is about wizards and magic and Dark
Lord's and kids get into it because it's
also about so much more and then their
parents get into it and then their
friends get into it and it started of
revolution there's no other word for it
so there's no surprise that Hollywood
came a-knockin and everybody was just
dying to know about the adaptation and
that's the key word here adaptation
I didn't choose either of the first two
Harry Potter films because as good as
they are they are pretty much page to
screen adaptations Chris Columbus did a
great job but they didn't really veer
they just brought the world to life the
kids were good the the monsters were
good but they were a kind of
surface-level then comes alfonso cuarón
and this movie yes it's the third movie
yes it builds on the first two but it is
a standalone movie because it takes a
book and takes it to the next level it
is a true idea of an adaptation it's not
word-for-word
it's not
point for plot point this is a movie
that takes all the the things that make
a movie a movie visuals music sound
acting CGI all of it and puts it
together and elevates the story and
brings it to a life in a way that blew
me away
blew millions of people away it made 800
million worldwide was second highest
grossing film of that year 2004 and it
just proved to people even not fantasy
people even not Harry Potter people my
dad had never read the books he didn't
see the first two movies he saw this
movie and was like oh I want to see more
of this so it does standalone - it
brought all the themes it brought the
fact that Harry Potter is a magical
world but that it is layered it's a
coming-of-age story it's a story about
friendship it's a story about doing
what's right even when it's difficult
it's beautiful it's scary it's deep it
does not talk down to children it is
everything I want in a movie not just a
movie based on kids books so for me it's
just one of the best movies ever made
and it's just what happens to be based
on one of the best kids book ever
written Wow thank you so much Rachel Dan
Merle yeah there are a lot of choices
but similarly there was one movie that
jumped into my head instantly and that I
did was no other option for me and
that's the Wizard of Oz one of the best
movies ever made period end of sentence
turn the page no more discussion The
Wizard of Oz made 1939 it will turn I
believe unless my math is around 80
years old next year it is still a
standard it is still a staple it is
still a must-see for anyone who's
interested in the film it is a must-see
for kids is a must-see for adults and
this is a movie that was made in 1939
but when you look at it apart from a
couple of model shots has not aged a day
because they got the setting right they
got to look right
the production design the cinematography
it's beautiful now just for the look of
it not not only because in 1939 it was
one of the most effective uses of color
it is still one of the most beautiful
films ever made and Judy Garland one of
the most I'm gonna use your term here
how iconic performances and movie
history but that entire cast
Jack Hailey and Ray Bolger and Bert Lahr
Margaret Hamilton the Wicked Witch of
the West one of the best villains in any
movie ever there are a small handful of
movies that you can legitimately call
timeless and The Wizard of Oz is
timeless it is as good today as it was
the day that it was released in 1939 it
is the gold standard for how to adapt a
fantasy book to a modern day audience
and tell it in a compelling and human
way and I don't think that there's
another choice for this question I love
Harry Potter
I respect Harry Potter they're fun
movies Azkaban is one of the better
Harry Potter movies but when you put it
up against the Wizard of Oz one of the
best movies ever made it's hard for me
to draw any comparison between the two
it's not a bad movie mine just happens
to be one of the best movies ever made
Wow
two great movies now go ahead and take
the piss out of each other's choices
it's hard to when it's the Wizard of Oz
I will grant you it is one of the best
movies of all time however I will take
issue with that is not a very faithful
adaptation and it didn't have anything
to do with the fact that it was adapted
for the screen because they're two
different mediums it had to do with
rights so there's a little you know
difference between that movie in my film
in terms of adaptations they had to do
what they had to do based on what they
had the right to wear Steve cloves and
cuarón did what they did because it was
the right thing to do to make this the
best film in Harry Potter series best
children's adaptation movie of all time
it is far more than just fun I honestly
like what Harry Potter has done what
this film has done in terms of for
reading for filmmaking for telling
stories coming-of-age stories for
telling stories where kid can relate to
even in a fantastical world like yes I
love Dorothy and there are lessons to be
learned and yes Margaret Hamilton and
the Wicked Witch of the West but we got
Voldemort okay we have Harry and
Hermione we have a much bigger cast a
much more sprawling story even within
just the Prisoner of Azkaban
it's still giving you layers upon layers
upon layers and I would argue as much as
both as beloved as Wizard of Oz is I
think the Harry Potter movies do more
for what you take away from the film but
the Wizard of Oz did would I think any
adaptation and in a cinematic sense
strives to do which was it didn't just
live up to the source material it
transcended the source material Prisoner
of Azkaban will always be viewed as a
good movie but it's always going to be
viewed also in the lens of the book was
it as good as the book is it faithful to
the book it took the best parts of the
book left out the worst parts of the
book it's always a comparison to JK
Rowling's book I think that Wizard of Oz
took a well-known story and became the
definitive version of that story and
when you're in adapting a story to the
screen isn't that what you're shooting
for isn't that what you want to do is to
cinematically look at the story take the
best parts take the parts that you know
will work adjust the parts that you
think are gonna make it a better movie
and that's what they did with Wizard of
Oz they wrote great music no the music's
not in the book but they wrote fantastic
ageless music these are standards still
today they're viewed as some of the best
musical moments ever captured on film
again Prisoner of Azkaban as could pay
Azkaban I'm gonna say gas cap an because
I'm just gonna get corrected at nothing
Prisoner of Azkaban is a great Harry
Potter movie but it's not even
I don't think universally acknowledged
as the best one personally as a fan of
the series
I like Goblet of Fire I like order the
Phoenix I think Azkaban is good but I
also think that it gets a little bogged
down at the end and it's it's it's good
and I think it got a lot of credit for
the fact that it was the first one to
break the mold because you're right the
first one in the second one where it
wrote page to screen adaptations and
then this one came out and was like oh
wow okay so you can add a little style
to these things and I think that's one
of the reason that it stands out so much
but again I I would not say that Harry
Potter and the Prisoner of Azkaban is a
classic it's a timeless film there's not
enough time to have gone by though it's
an it's apples and oranges like in 20
years in 30 years we very well could be
saying that and I would say that the
chances are very good of saying that
because of the iconic nature that story
has already achieved in less than 20
years since she wrote the books and
but almost 14 years since the film came
out give it time I could guarantee you
that that would happen now it's like I
said apples and oranges Wizard of Oz has
had the time and it has stood the test
of time I'm not arguing that but in
terms of achievements in terms of music
and it was nominated for a Best Score
the Oscars is nominee for Best Visual
Effects Gary Oldman is in this movie
there's so much about this that will
absolutely stand the test of time and I
don't fare it's think it's fair to hold
the it's more a new movie against it in
this argument
no worries either way but you brought up
something regarding The Wizard of Oz
being unfaithful to its book and they
were dealing with the rights issues are
you able to elaborate on that do certain
things like its its ruby slippers in the
movie it's silver shoes in the books
there's certain characters that don't
show up in the movie certain order of
things that happen there are a series of
books by l frank Baum and they are
wonderful books and there's been other
adaptations that have been a little bit
more faithful but in terms of what I'm
saying is that the filmmakers and the
and the writers at that time you know
we're making decisions outside of their
control in terms of rights and you know
made a movie as close as they could and
called it the Wizard of Oz based on what
they had the ability to work with
whereas I think it's more impressive
when you have the source material and
you have the author working with you and
you're making the creative decisions as
to I am choosing not to use this form
change choosing to choose to change this
or use that because it's the best way to
tell this story via film versus view but
I've never heard anybody say when they
watch The Wizard of Oz like oh man if
they'd only use that weird porcelain
brand from those books again it's like
they took the books and they made them
better they understood what makes a
great movie they let's make them read
why read they look better than it's over
I guess you know it's it's this idea of
like just because it's not a straight
adaptation that shouldn't be knocked
against my movie just like you know they
they knock stuff out of Prisoner of
Azkaban they knocked a bunch of stuff
out of that movie they changed that's
every book adaptation changes stuff and
I'm not holding the fact that it's new
against it I'm not you know I'm not
saying like Harry Potter and the
Prisoner of Azkaban you know will never
be will be forgotten in 30 years I'm not
gonna say that I do think that Harry paw
the prisoner of azkaban will be
remembered as part of a series of great
movies I don't know if that particular
movie is going to be universally and
widely acclaimed as the one that stands
out from the pack
Bar None I think there are too many
other movies in that series that people
enjoy I think people are going to see
the series and the totality and again I
have a very hard time believing that
idiot let's forget Harry Potter
what other adaptation of a children's
book has stood the test of time the way
that The Wizard of Oz has as one of the
maybe 10 best movies ever made and it's
not just me saying that it's it's
numerous critics list the AFI can so
many other people can you respond to
that
oh the that claim that why or that
question why does Azkaban stand out over
the rest of the Harry Potter film I mean
I already think it does if you look on
Rotten Tomatoes it's the second highest
percentage and the only one that's
higher is Deathly Hallows part-2 and
that's unfair because it's a part two
it's two movies make the one it's always
lauded in terms of the most creative as
the most stylistic is the most that has
a sense of from cuarón and bringing out
the themes of the Harry Potter books in
terms of the relatability the
groundedness it's not just about the
magic so many of the other films well
yeah of course they're enjoyable and
they're fun I you talked to 10 critics
and nine are going to say that Azkaban
is the one that stands out because it's
the one that stands out on the deeper
levels the more meaningful levels and
also in the filmmaking side of things
just the look and the feel and the tone
of that belief do you experience those
books when you read it and that's the
one Harry Potter film above the rest of
them where you get the same experience
watching it okay I've got one more
question for both of you guys
you're both babysitting a real bratty
piece of crap just this kid you know
devil child I'm talking some Damian The
Omen kind of action here and you need to
get this child excited about your movie
okay I want you to talk to look into the
camera talk to this child and get them
excited about your film whoever wants to
go first jump right in
we're why we're here where this right
there there's a light on a different
camera okay I think I'm like it's the
right one okay Trevor put the toys down
and sit down for a second
we're gonna watch a movie this is a
movie about a kid a lot like you who you
know what you think you think your life
sucks you know what she does too and she
gets whisked away to this land there is
brightness there's music there's joy and
if you don't like those things and
you're gonna learn how to like them and
by the way you little bugger you need to
learn a little something about movies
too so you're gonna sit down and you're
gonna watch one of the best movies ever
made you've seen Harry Potter 15 times
already I'm gonna show you one of the
great movies ever made and this is a
movie that everyone should see and I
guarantee you any kid and I'm including
you Trevor is gonna like this movie
because this is a timeless classic movie
and it doesn't age and I'm not just
addressing Trevor now I'm addressing
society because I don't do so great with
the bits how I just like to talk about
how great these movies are and why the
Wizard of Oz is peerless well that was a
great answer and thank you for playing
along with the bit Rachel get this kid
in line and get him on the Harry Potter
track all right Trevor you and I both
know that you would much rather watch a
movie that's got magic spells crazy
creatures a Dark Lord running around
escaped convicts kids breaking rules
left and right but it's also about
friendship it's also about overcoming
all kinds of crazy things
it's about casting spells being taken
away into a magical world you will get
whisked away in this movie and you will
have so much fun you will see yourself
in it sure Wizard of Oz is amazing but
you and I both know that this is the
modern family film this is the modern
kids film and that you and I are just
gonna sit down and watch this and love
this Trevor hang on Trevor they never
wanted to drop a house on somebody this
person drops a house on somebody in the
first five minutes of this movies and
it's everything that she just said
except a better version of it you get
wow man why the parents hire two
babysitters for the one kid I don't know
it's a bad kid oh yeah it's a bad bad
true true true you know what let's start
with our friend lon Harris but not a lot
of facts a check all the facts were
right on it is true that Rotten Tomatoes
has definitely Hallows in the first spot
and then Azkaban is second with 91%
rancor as well has them in the same rank
part two definitely always number one
then Azkaban number two it was the
second highest grossing film of 2004 I
made about eight hundred dollars
it was nominated for two Oscars
comparatively a Wizard of Oz was
nominated for six Oscars and won two
Best Original Song and Best Original
Score crazy it lost out that year for
Best Picture
- Gone with the Wind why did I think
those two movies competing for Best
Picture against each other I like I like
both of these arguments I thought both
of the fighters made really good points
I do feel like in this case it is hard I
think Rachael started from from a behind
position I keep doing that what am i
doing it's very hard to make the case
against Wizard of Oz and I thought that
her main point that it changes a lot in
the adaptation like well we the question
was best movie based on children's book
not most careful faithful adaptation of
a children's book so in this one I got
to go with that all right one oh right
there yeah I agree with lon
you guys were both lobbing some really
good points at each other and I'm just
breaking it down right here you know
Rachel you you did start again as the
underdog here and you Dan really panned
the picture of a strong film also you
when you were describing your film to
little Trevor
like you said magic and crazy creatures
it could have been either films that
wasn't quite why your film stood out but
then Dan you made some wonderful points
about why the Wizard of Oz is timeless
filmmaking but I feel like your argument
got a little bit too rooted in the
timelessness of this film and I feel
like Rachel painted the picture of why
this is the better adapt
so because of that I'm gonna go with
Rachel and send it once again to the
fans to decide all right
it is fairly overwhelming The Wizard of
Oz takes it with 71% while Prisoner of
Azkaban gets 28% some of the things I
noticed from looking at the chat a lot
of love for Narnia Paddington so much
love for Willy Wonka a lot of sexy gifts
of Carrie always and Princess Bride
thank you I will take them all day
family people in the chat are like
having side bets which I do not endorse
but I will read yes we get like we got
movie fights on FanDuel a couple of
Twitter things I appreciated at mumbles
Merrill Key wrote I'd argue that Azkaban
makes children want to read which is a
good thing at dr. Matt Zappa wrote jaws
it was a PG movie and to quote Mitch
Hedberg any book is a kids movie if the
kid can read okay yeah by that rationale
Fifty Shades of Grey movie okay not for
kids
or anybody no not for anybody anyone
know except me and my mom look that up
on the screen donkey show all right Wow
we are locked up at 1-1 what a battle
this is the next question supplied by a
[Laughter]
very limited Running Room this is so
exciting okay so what we're going to do
I've got a hat full of directors each of
you are going to pick a director
no look okay okay now or no yes go ahead
and look Rachel who did you get Joel
Schumacher Joel Schumacher Dan M night
Shyamalan Wow
Schumacher Shyamalan holy schnikeys the
question is what director who still
hasn't gotten a shot should get their
own Star Wars trilogy what director who
still hasn't gotten a shot should get
their own Star Wars trilogy its round
number three Dan Merle you are going
first Rachel you will go second Dan have
at it
well I'm glad I didn't get this question
five years ago and I'm very happy that I
got this question today because M night
Shyamalan man did he go through a rough
patch he went through a really bad patch
of movies but he seems to come out to
have come out on the other side the
visit was somewhat of return to form for
him stylistically a split was a huge hit
and reinvigorated a shared universe that
people didn't even know existed he was
able to pull off one of the great
surprises of quite some time in in
connecting those two movies to this
unbreakable universe which he is now
developing so what better time to let M
night kind of have the cinematic rebirth
than to allow him to bring his talent as
a filmmaker that we know that he is
capable of great style of great vision
as a filmmaker if he's if his worst
impulses are not allowed to run free and
guess what you're gonna be working for
Kathleen Kennedy and Disney the place
where bad impulses go to die you will be
under the the shepherding of a creative
team and I think what you're gonna get
is a Star Wars trilogy that allows the
best of them night Shyamalan to shine
through the the promise that we saw in
movies like signs and the sixth sense
and even stylistically and some of his
bombs I will say that for all of the
terrible dialogue and after earth look
at just the sci-fi setting and the
fools and the world that he created
there if you watch it on mute man that
is a hell of a movie and I think that
this is a good time in his career to
allow him to come out of this bad patch
and really develop something interesting
and unique and I think that's what he
can do with Star Wars thanks Dan Rachael
Cushing I think the thing that gets lost
a lot of times when talking about Star
Wars is that it is a family fun
franchise and I gotta say Joel
Schumacher taking this family fun
franchise on is a match made in heaven
this is the guy that gave us the Lost
Boys this is the guy that gave us
Flatliners he's got a sci-fi bent he can
bring that to the table this is also the
guy that's done great dramatic fare the
client
this guy's worked with oscar-winning
performers and actors they can bring
those people to the table I think that
if we're talking about resurgence is
here that it is the definitely the time
for Joel Schumacher yes he's had a few
misses just like mr. Shawn Alon we've
had the Batman universe but hey I got a
weak spot for Batman Forever and I think
there's a lot of good stuff in there and
I think a lot of that fits with the Star
Wars universe and that this is the time
for Star Wars to come back to the whole
family and be that franchise that it was
intended to be and has gone a little off
track here and there and joel
schumacher's absolutely the person to
bring all these elements back together
Wow all right unsheath those lightsabers
and clash do you know who else made the
exact same argument that you just made
about Joel Schumacher Warner Brothers
when they handed Batman to him they said
we're tired of all this adult stuff and
we want to give this back to the
families and sell toys and what happened
Joel Schumacher did with the Joker and
Catwoman in the penguin and the Riddler
and two-face were not able to do and he
killed Batman he killed him dead he
killed him so dead Christopher Nolan had
to come back and rebirth him I don't
want to give Joel Schumacher the keys to
another franchise and tell him make it
for the kids
we've seen where that road leads and I'm
not ready for neon Khorasan and and the
Millennium Falcon going under big
statues of shirtless dudes holding the
planets on their shoulders
I don't need it I've seen it I've been
there he has done some good work that
was 30 years ago that was 20 years ago
at best
M night Shyamalan is a guy who yes has
also done some bad work but he isn't a
career resurgence and one movie is not a
career resurgence I will just put that
out there all it takes would be one
movie for Jules from Joel Schumacher to
be in the same exact place you said is
no there are movies that you cannot
watch there's that bad with Shyamalan
they can say it about both of them you
can say the resurgence aspect for both
of them so let's get on the same page
with where's Joel Schumacher's
resurgence Batman and Robin was in one
night does not guarantee a Star Wars
trailer it's been 20 years where where
is good Joel Schumacher where is he
where is he coming from where is he
it's in him I believe that if in him I
know that it's in an ocean I'm one
because we're watching it happen we're
watching it happen before our very eyes
splits overrated just saying oh you may
think so but you know it's a Star Wars
universe it was gonna be a horror story
but that's not okay bottom line you
bring up something interesting Rachel
I'm gonna pose this question to both of
you
what will your director bring to the
Star Wars universe that we don't quite
have in the Star Wars universe what will
their style what will their choices add
to Star Wars either of you jump in I
think that there's the the fun I'm going
back to the fun I want this to be the
the family franchise not that it doesn't
in some respects in the new trilogy but
I think that there could be pushed more
forward I think the balance could be
better
I think yes Schumacher killed Batman
with Batman and Robin but there are
aspects of Batman Forever that truly
work and I think that they could
absolutely work in this realm as well
the Riddler in that film is great the
look of that film is a lot of fun the
music is great okay we don't need Val
Kilmer in Star Wars but there are other
actors that Schumacher absolutely has
worked with that he could bring to the
table and yes do the same point that
you're making about Shyamalan he will
have Kathleen Kennedy working with him
he will have the Star Wars group backing
him and I think with the steady hand
that they could bring that 20 years will
disappear in a heartbeat and he will
bring fun
actually the Star Wars universe we've
seen what happens when Star Wars is is
guided into the fun family franchise
zone that is the birthplace of Jar Jar
Binks that is the best place that was
pre everything that's in place now
though but that is the birthplace of
everything that we hate though we don't
want to see the Star Wars movies go back
to that I want Star Wars movies that
aren't interesting and I'm not shaman
it's not just a horror director look you
know on the surface sixth sense is it
about ghosts it has ghosts in it but
when you'd go deep down into it that is
a family drama it is as much about like
about more than twenty years ago it is a
bit it is about as much about Haley Joel
Osment and Bruce Willis and the mom as
anything else unbreakable is a superhero
film after earth is a sci-fi film split
would you just watch that on mute split
which but you're talking about you're
saying that he only has one genre and
I'm saying that's not true I'm so there
John well he's what genres Joel
Schumacher not bad at these days you
name me three films from 20 years ago
I'm naming you a good film that was a
hit that built the cinematic universe
that came out last year and is a
psychological thriller as much as it is
a horror movie I'm talking about a
filmmaker that right now is on his
upswing what was the last movie that
Joel Schumacher directed okay Wow I mean
kudos to both of you
I mean you you you spun gold out of
garbage when some of those arguments uh
but at the end of the day I felt like
Dan dealt you a fatal blow with that
Warner Brothers Batman killing rant I
mean that was unrecoverable I give this
third argument to Dan lon
well I I did I thought it was a little
closer than you did yeah that was I mean
it is only eight years between Batman
and Robin and Batman Begins a point I
sort of it hoped Rachel would would
bring out the weeding here but it I
don't know if that's necessarily killing
the character i I liked I liked a lot of
the points that Rachel got in I do think
Batman Forever looks cool it has a great
soundtrack
I do think Sixth Sense is a horror movie
but I will say ultimate oh and to add a
fact the last film that Joel Schumacher
directed it was called trespass it's
from 2011 it's not good
but he has also made so you did direct a
few house of cards episodes some of the
other ultimately though I do think that
Dan made the stronger case for why
Shyamalan would be a good fit right now
at this moment in his career so I do
have to disappoint Dan takes the round
Danielle take us to the Internet
alright well just out of curiosity for
the blind picks it was overwhelmingly
going for M night Shyamalan with 80% to
schumacher's 19% unfortunately L did
hear me I think a bunch of people when
Dan was talking about the Schumacher
Star Wars a bunch of people thought they
heard me say oh sell it and I said I was
like you sold me be so mad if I was
sitting over here everything they would
say like well yeah that sounds good
nightmare factory crusher your split
opinions really yeah yeah I thought that
was gonna and going over to Twitter we
had @j Peck 1098 said what about a Star
Wars trilogy directed by Martin Scorsese
with a little dead gif to accompany it
which seemed fun nice and then you can
have like DeNiro bringing DiCaprio to
the dark side go check it out and then
I'm at know min Dean 27 going back to
our last round sent me um hey Danielle
meet Trevor and it's just like I believe
it's from problems little devil costume
egg dankmemes Thank You Danielle and
Rachel um again you you made a valiant
effort but I would have brought up last
airbender they like
I'm like someone killed a potential huge
franchise there but she went Lost Boys
and Flatliners great poles probably yes
absolutely absolutely is classic if
you've not seen Lost Boys check it out
by the way you should check out the
speed round which is about to happen
right now so it is to one Stan okay but
it is anybody's ballgame we have four
speed round questions the first person
to get four points for answers awarded
to them takes the game we have for
questions here dan is up to two one
and again the speed round works thusly I
ask the question the first person to
answer will go first they will each get
twenty seconds each 20 seconds 20
seconds and then ten second rebuttals
Rachel are you ready Dan you feeling it
let's do this let's do this question
number one who would be a better
fictional character than Lobo for
Michael Bay to adapt
do I hate better fictional character
than Lobo mojo from the x-men universe
mojo 5 Uncle Sam Uncle Sam
alright we have mojo first Uncle Sam
Michael Bay adaptation Dan Merle you
spoke first 20 seconds begins when you
speak Mojo's and x-men character is like
the mutant version of Michael Bay he
makes entertainment for the masses he
wants to dump people down he's all about
bombast he's all about spectacle this is
the character that Michael Bay was born
to adapt into a motion picture and it
allows him to indulge in all of his
worst instincts because that's what the
character requires you wanted to recruit
to adapt the character faithfully give
him a character that's like himself time
Rachel okay how about let's go positive
instead of negative and let's embrace
the things that Michael Bay does well
and that is action and that is
patriotism and that is heroism Michael
Sam calls you to serve your country so
let's give Michael Bay the ultimate call
to arms and call people to serve their
country in the heroic ways and give them
the explosions give them the battles
give them the things that he does well
and that people go to the theater to
spend money on time ten seconds oh my
god the last person I need recruiting
people to fight for our country is
Michael Bay he's everything we don't
need we don't need to blow more stuff up
we don't need to get dumber we don't
need to get shallower you know who does
mojo I want Michael Bay doing comics I
say give him 13 hours the rock all of
these movies were what he did well and
this would allow him to continue to do
the thing that he does well why tear
somebody down why not hold them up time
Wow all right Danielle yes this is the
round where Danielle chimes in okay um
man that was really hard both obviously
really really good points
as much as I appreciate Uncle Sam and I
think my brain went to one of the many
Oh connotations of Michael Sam
immediately before you took it up to a
recruitment technique I do I want to see
mojo on screen so bad and I do you think
that if anyone could do Mojo's kind of
version of crash TV mojo was the person
who did x-men babies he brought us the
sixth arm spiral I do I got to go with
dance argument when he said mutant
Michael Bay I was like you havin some go
with damn okay 104 Dan lon
I yeah I mean I don't know the mojo
character that well so I don't I don't
have that to go on both do sound like
very appropriate projects for mr. Bay
but I really did like the outside of the
box choice I don't know if anybody's
ever fought that somebody should adapt a
like mascot or a brand in that way I
really like to Rachel wet with it I'm
going with Rachel okay it's 1:1 so that
comes down to me to decide you know what
I
I like Rachel's out-of-the-box choice
but I just don't feel like we got quite
enough of what that would look like and
I thought Dan cut it down calling some
of Michael Bay's more hatred quote
unquote patriotic work a little bit I
mean - you didn't say this but a little
bit jingoistic and you painted that
picture and and then you gave us a
clearer picture of mojo and I don't feel
like you knocked that down quite enough
so I got to give it to Dan
dan is up three two one I work one great
comment that I loved on Twitter at
clowny J wrote Michael Bay should do a
jubilee movie all fireworks explosions
and nineties puns
oh hell yeah like Michael Bay couldn't
do nineties puns all day oh I love that
all right let's go to the second
question of the speed round by the way
this is potentially for the game Rachel
you need to take this to continue the
game Dan you get it and you go home a
winner okay who is the overall best
actor who has played a spider-man
villain
alfred molina thinking of all the
spider-man movies in my head there's so
many terrible ones I'll go with Willem
Dafoe Willem Dafoe Alfred Molina that
would be a great buddy comedy okay
Rachel you spoke first
your time begins when you speak now
Raimi spider-man - that's all you need
to say if the best spider-man movie out
there there's no question you have a
villain who is doesn't see himself as
the villain that is the best kind of
villain there is Alfred Molina is top
notch award worthy actor he takes that
character he is subsumed by the AI in
the arms and he's got to come full
circle he's the perfect antithesis to
Peter because they're both scientists
time I love Efrain Molina he's very
genial in that movie he's very genial in
most movies that I see Alfred Molina and
what I love about Willem Dafoe is he can
play a cartoon character like the Green
Goblin and he can also take out such a
grounded performance that he's currently
nominated for in the Florida Project and
do them both he can go over the top and
Boondock Saints he can do platoon he is
he defines the chameleon actor and I'm
not I'm 10 second rebuttal this is about
the spider-man villain though and he's
so over the top is the Green Goblin that
it's not that scary it is much more
relatable to play the villain Doc Ock
because of the way that he relates to
Peter and the arc that he goes through
the course of the movie I think that
they're both great villains but I think
the question was who's the better actor
I think that Willem Dafoe is the better
actor Alfred Molina is great at playing
the kind of characters that he's that he
plays into his tight but Willem Dafoe
can play literally any kind of character
and do them all well time wow this is
very close Rachel you really painted an
amazing picture of Molina's Doc Ock and
juxtaposing him against spider-man that
actually made me want to go back and
re-watch the movie just for that aspect
you got me excited about Molina's Doc
Ock and it is great and maybe the best
spider-man villain but the question was
who's the overall best actor
was played a spider-man villain and I
feel like damn threaded that needle when
he praised Willem Dafoe's Green Goblin
performance but also he's nominated for
Florida Project and Dan cited other
pieces from his body of work so just as
far as answering that question got to
give it to Dan let's go to Danielle yeah
I do I do have to agree with that one in
as much as as good as the arguments
where I the spider-man 2 is great and I
think before homecoming it was like my
favorite performance of anyone in any of
the spider-man's but Dan's point about
how Willem Dafoe can play both the
cartoon and do a grounded performance
chameleon actor those really won me over
I will say to the check and to everyone
adding me yes Michael Keaton is awesome
yes didn't think about my yeah yeah so
you're going with yeah giving it Dan you
take the game
Rachel Cushing
what an amazing maiden voyage this was
you were great want some stuff watch
this row down what screen junkies watch
Collider I'm in and about all of them
and it's been so much fun to hang out
with such great movie lovers oh and it's
so much fun to hang out with a great
movie lover such as yourself you I was
at the Schmo down Awards a couple weeks
ago and you how many awards did you win
three three including Rookie of the Year
and you kill it and thank you for coming
in and just gracing us with your amazing
movie knowledge appreciate it
Dan Merle I was not nominated for an
Eastman Awards because I guess they
forgot that I played this year I retired
no I am retired and yeah I get 15 tweets
a week telling me that I need to watch
my back because somebody's coming for
every shred of anything that ever built
this mode out so it was a pleasure
fighting against Rachel and I'm here I'm
here
just in general I'm here the order is
like unless someone's car breaks down
yes
I'm glad I cut the brake lines on mark
and wrinkles car so I can compete today
yeah it's like I'm sure mark will be
back and I'm glad I could keep his
podium warm right but it is like Rachel
you were expecting a fight mark and
Draco Dan like stepped in with a plum
but then it's like oh great I have to
you know go against like IB I was going
and gonna go against one boss but I have
to go against like the big boss or like
it's like unenviable but you did
fantastic Dan thank you sir for stepping
up short notice
Juan Harris that's me Thank You Daniel
on anything a plug oh just follow me on
Twitter at L ons and find me right here
wherever fine screen jockey shows are
made yes a lot is very funny Twitter
he's always tweeting just deep cuts
about movies that make me laugh and
sometimes make me feel funny okay Daniel
Radford fantastic I can't wait to have
the crusher back I'm super excited
I believe you know this is the first
time that I I don't know if you did
movie freud's previously I know this is
a long history but like yeah this was a
fantastic first fight really amazing I
can't wait to have you back and you guys
can just find me you guys know where to
find me
you literally find me all throughout the
show find me there hell yeah and I'm Hal
Rudnick hit me up on Twitter and
Instagram for that dank and I want
to thank jte I want to thank max in the
booth Billy hope you're having a great
honeymoon bye bye everybody